bien on va lire on va continuer notre
lecture que nous avions commencé hier
dans les écoles 37 et hier nous nous
sommes arrêtés sur
la prophétie la plus la plus grande et
la plus célèbre qui s'arrête donc au
verset 14 celle de la résurrection des
ossements desséchés
mère est une suite au chapitre 37 du
livre du prophète ezéchiel une suite sur
laquelle on s'arrête sont en général
très peu parce qu'ils me voient ça pose
un énorme problème
on lit à partir du verset 15
la parole de l'éternel me fut adressée
entre en ces mots toi fils d'homme prend
une pièce de bois écrit dessus à judas
et au fils d'israël qui lui sont
associées plan suis une autre pièce de
bois écrit dessus à joseph bois
d'ephraïm et à toute la maison d'israël
qui lui est associé rapprochées l'une de
l'autre que tu n'es qu'une seule pièce
de bois de sorte qu'elle soit unie dans
ta main parce que les gens de ton peuple
te dire on ne nous expliquera tout parce
que cela signifie puis leur répondra
ainsi parle le seigneur l'éternel voici
je prends le bois de joseph conrad à
mende et frame et les tribus d'israël
qui lui sont associés je les joindre et
hautbois de judas jan fabre et un seul
bois il serait venu dans la main
les pièces de bois sur lesquels tu écris
rassurons dans ta main sous leurs yeux
tu leur diras ainsi parle le seigneur
l'éternel voici je prends désiste khalid
entre les nations ils sont allés je les
rassemblerai de toutes parts et je les
ferai revenus sur leur territoire je
ferai de une seule nation dans le pays
dans les montagnes d'israël une aux ont
tous un même roy et ne formeront plus de
nations et ne seront plus divisée en
deux royaumes ils se souviendront
plupart leur idole par leurs
abominations partout le crime je laisse
ouvrait de tous les lieux qu'ils ont
habité où ils ont pêché gelé purifierait
ils seront pas que je serai leurs yeux
mon serviteur david sera le roi ils
auront tous un seul berger suivront mes
ordonnances les observons les
prescriptions et mettront en pratique
nous habiterons deux pays que j'ai donné
à mon serviteur jacob et comptabilité
vos pairs les habitants ont eu leur fils
est le fils de leur fils à perpétuité et
mon serviteur sodaville sera leur prince
pour toujours je conclurai avec une
alliance de paix il y aura une alliance
éternelle avec eux jeudi d'établir et je
démultiplierait j'établirai mon
sanctuaire au milieu d'eux pour toujours
à demeure sera pas mieux je serais
aujourd'hui sur mon peuple et la nation
reconnaîtront que je suis l'éternel qui
sanctifie sera aide parce que mon
sanctuaire sera pour toujours au milieu
d'eux
avons ici une des très nombreuses
prophéties
sur le rassemblement des douze tribus
d'israël
les tribu de juda et ceux qu'on appelle
les dix tribus perdues
je voudrais ce soir que nous arrêtions
sur cette question des dix tribus
perdues
d'abord
qu'appelle-t-on dix tribus perdues
alors il faut faire un petit peu
d'histoire biblique
vous savez que le peuple d'israël est
composée des descendants des douze fils
de jacob qui sont les douze patriarche
et dès qu'elles vont être douze tribus
qui ensemble vont constituer le peuple
d'israël
ce sont ces douze tribus il s'empare du
pays au moment de la conquête par josué
et qui se partagent deux pays en douce
par chaque tribu ayant une part de cet
ensemble qui a été ainsi conquis
et plus tard ce sont sur ces douze
tribus qui forment l'ensemble du peuple
d'israël que va régner le grand roi
david et ensuite son fils salomon
et puis vous souvenez que à la mort du
vieux du roi salomon alors un drame se
produit
dix tribus des dix tribus du nord pour
se séparer de deux autres tribus
ils sont les deux tribus du sud
est de 7 ce schisme de ses divisions
vont être deux royaumes souvent a connu
ce souvent en guerre les uns contre de
l'un contre l'autre le royaume du sud
qui va prendre le nom de royaume de juda
capitale jérusalem et le royaume du nord
il va prendre le nom de royaume d'israël
et qui est composé dé d'istres des dix
tribus du nord royaume d'israël ou
encore royaume d'ephraïm du nom de la
plus grande des tribus qui le compose de
la même manière que le royaume de juda
était composé de la plus grande des deux
tribus judas et benjamins qui
constituait le royaume du sud
en 722 avant jésus-christ
le roi
sargon ii 2 d'acier met fin à
l'existence du royaume du nord
et il va déporter eu la plus grande
partie des habitants de cette région de
ce royaume du nord des représentants de
ces dix tribus et il va les déportés en
particulier dans l'eau dans la région du
haut tu feras tu la région dont il est
beaucoup question actuellement dans
l'actualité la région de mossoul kirkouk
et c'est
le royaume du sud le royaume de juda va
subsister encore environ deux siècles
et puis en 586 avant jésus-christ
les successeurs des assyriens que sont
les chaldéens
dirigé par le rouennais vanessa pense
vont s'emparer de jérusalem et procéder
à la déportation du royaume du sud
là le lieu géographique de cette
déportation sera quelque peu différent
de celui des du royaume du nord les
habitants des dix tribus avaient été
déportés dans le nord de la mésopotamie
les habitants du royaume du sud seront
déportées dans le sud de la mésopotamie
sophie et aucun rapport avec le nord et
le sud bien évidemment c'était tout
simplement pour des raisons de commodité
vraisemblablement que les rois
décider de ses affectations la
536 avant jose avant jésus-christ le roi
cyrus qui s'est emparée de babylone et
camille fin à l' empire chaldéens
va
permettre aux habitants du royaume du
sud aux habitants de judas les judéens
ou encore les juifs
parce que juif ça signifie tout
simplement judéens
il autorise ces gens là à revenir et à
reconstruire l ademe et le temps
c'est le retour de l'exil que nous et
décrits dans les livres d arrêt de nimy
par exemple et de ceux de 7,2 ce retour
de l'exil va naître le deuxième royaume
juif
or ce qu'ils vont revenir de l'exil sont
uniquement et ça c'est faut le souligner
uniquement les descendants du royaume du
nord
ceux du royaume pendant son intérim du
sud excusez moi
ceux du royaume du nord ne vont
absolument pas revenir
et quand on parle aujourd'hui du peuple
juif
c est uniquement des descendants de ces
deux tribus judas et benjamin que nous
parlons avec sa tribu de lévis c'était
une tribu qui était extra territoriale
on pourrait dire
mais les habitants du royaume du nord ne
sont jamais revenus dans le pays
d'israël
qu'en est il advenu d'eux
lyster
et les historiens et bien
son dense devant une impasse
et ils supposent que les habitants du
royaume du nord se sont assimilés au
sein des nations aux syndicats au milieu
desquels ils ont été dispersés
si bien que ces dix tribus ont disparu
totalement et définitivement de la scène
de l'histoire
or il ya un problème
c'est que la prophétie que nous avons lu
et de nombreux autres prophéties que
nous n'avons pas lu mais que nous
aurions pu lire également
nous parle pour les temps de la fin du
retour des dix tribus perdues
commencé dix tribus perdues
qui ont disparu dans la nature qui se
sont assimilés parmi les nations
pourront être revenir au temps de la fin
on est devant ici une quasi
impossibilité
et quand j'étais à l'école biblique en
angleterre il ya de cela bien longtemps
je me souviens d'un commentaire que
j'avais vu sur ce texte qui en substance
disait ceci il ne faut pas s'attendre à
un retour physique des dix tribus autant
de la fin mais il s'agit d'une réalité
spirituelle
le commentaire n'expliquait pas très
bien en quoi cette étude réalité
spirituelle et comment il fallait
comprendre ce texte on sentait que le
commentateur était particulièrement
embarrassés par ce type de prophétie
par conséquent même au sein du monde
évangélique
on ne croit pas et l'on ne croit plus au
retour des dix tribus perdues
par contre le peuple juif n'a cessé d'y
croire
et il était bien conscient que c'était
une
une quelque chose de difficile à
réaliser de difficile à comprendre mais
que c'était un des événements qui serait
marquant dans les temps de la fin les
temps de la fin qui serait marquée par
des actes miraculeux de la part de dieu
et parmi ces miracles qui marquerait les
temps de la fin il durer
les urgences la réapparition la
redécouverte et le retour des dix tribus
perdues
et la tradition juive va même jusqu'à
affirmer que le retour des dix tribus
perdues
sera le dernier signe avant la venue du
messie
quand réapparaître quand réapparaîtront
les dix tribus perdues et que le retour
recommencera alors on sera que le messie
est à la porte la venue du messie est
imminente
et dans l'histoire il ya toujours eu de
la part de très nombreux juifs une
volonté de retrouver de rentrer en
contact avec des tribus perdues
il ya un texte qui est intéressant dans
ce sens là aussi cet ex nous trouvons
dans le deuxième livre des rois au
chapitre 17
et au verset au verset 6
la 9e année doser le roi d'assyrie puis
ça m'arrive une des portes à israël en
assyrie il les fit habiter à allart sur
le fabre fleuve de gods and ainsi que
dans les villes des mèdes
donc ici nous avons une indication
géographique de l'endroit où ont été
déportés les dix tribus et par
conséquent si l'on veut faire des
recherches pour essayer de retrouver les
dix tribus perdues c'est évidemment par
là qu'il faut commencer
ces endroits étaient situés là vous vu
dans le nord de la mésopotamie sur le
hot flat et il est intéressant de noter
qu'il est question du fleuve de gohan
et dans la traduction araméenne de la
bible il y a une autre expression qu
apparaît à la place de flav fleuve de
gohan nous trouvons fleuve du sang battu
rhône
et le sens bayonne
c'est un fleuve mythique c'est un fleuve
légendaire que l'on trouve constamment
dans toutes les traditions juives
relatives aux dix tribus perdues
samba turone ça vient de shabbat
sang le sang bathium c'est un fleuve du
shabbat c'est le fleuve du shabbat la
tradition juive nous dit qu'il faut
chercher des dix tribus perdues tout
elles sont situées au delà du samba tron
les juifs les habitants nous plutôt les
descendants des deux tribus du sud sont
dispersés dans le monde entier on les
trouve dans le monde entier et il faut
s'attendre à les trouver dans le monde
entier
mais en ce qui concerne ceux de
du nord ils vont rester groupés et on a
un texte qui fait très très bien cette
différence dans le livre du prophète
isaïe au chapitre 11 nous dit ceci
que dans le ce temps là autant de la fin
autant de votants messianique le
seigneur et tendre à une seconde fois
ses mains pour ramener le reste de son
peuple qui sera dispersée en différents
endroits il rassemblera les néo dirait
et israël est née fuchs et houda des
quatre extrémités de la terre
n'est foot c et houda est né d'hier et
israël
deux termes qui sont presque synonyme
qui ne sont pas vraiment
rien dit qu deux types de déportation
née fuchs et houda ça veut dire les
disperser de judas
et les descendants de la tribu de juda
seront dispersées dans le monde entier
on y trouvera par tous dispersés comme
du blé que l'on jette
la summer jette pour le sommet il s'en
va dans toutes les directions
par contre pour ce qui concerne israël
c'est à dire le royaume du nord il est
question de gens qui sont des nids
dicrim c'est à dire qu'ils seront aussi
dé portée mais qui resteront groupés ils
resteront ensemble et leur leurs airs de
dispersion sera limité dans une aire
géographique très précise et très est
très limité et qui sera selon la
tradition l'armée plus dangereuse que la
bible qu'ils annoncent ce sera limité au
delà du sens bayonne
qu'est ce que le son bastion
le sens bayonne c'est un fleuve énorme
un fleuve extrêmement impétueux
extrêmement profond bref un fleuve qui
est tout simplement infranchissable
seulement comme son nom l'indiqué fleuve
du shabbat c'est un fleuve juifs et
comme tout bon juif le jour du shabbat
qu'est-ce qui fait il se repose
donc le jour du shabbat il cesse de
couler il est à sec
ce qui veut dire que le jour du shabbat
est le seul jour de la semaine où il est
possible de travaux de traversée le sens
bayonne
mais le jour du shabbat on n'a pas le
droit de voyager
alors on est coincé
ça veut dire que d'une manière ou d'une
autre
les dix tribus perdues elle ne peux pas
les atteindre on ne peut pas avoir de
contact avec elle parce que on ne peut
pas traverser le sens bayonne
mais quand viendra l'heure du
rassemblement des nids dire israël nous
avons parlé
les
dérives je sais pas comment on peut
traduire ça exactement en français enfin
disons les
l'idée portée peut-être quelque chose
comme ça
eh bien le sens bayonne s'asséchera
pour pouvoir justement permettre ce
rassemblement des du peuple d'israël qui
reformera un seul peuple avec des douze
tribus qui seront assemblés qui sont
réunifiées
or dans l'histoire il ya plusieurs
exemples où un certain nombre de gens
ont réussi à franchir le samba thiam
le premier exemple c'est au 9e siècle de
notre ère
quand un personnage très mystérieux se
présenter parmi les juifs d'espagne
au 9e siècle
l'espagne était la plus grande colonie
juive du monde là qu'il y avait le plus
de juifs
est arrivé donc en espagne pas mais les
juifs de ce pays un personnage qui
étaient noirs africains
et qui se faisait appeler eldad le dany
tu
es il prétendait qu'il a venaient d'un
pays très éloignés
qui étaient situées au delà de ce que
l'on appelait le royaume mythique devenu
prêtre jean et que là-bas il y avait un
royaume juif
très important qui était dirigée par une
reine juive et qui depuis des décennies
et des décennies
tenait tête aux armées de l'islam
bon son histoire était un peu
rocambolesque lui-même été noir on
n'avait pas tellement l'habitude de voir
des juifs noirs même si c'était pas un
juif c'était un israélite descendant de
la tribu de dana
la couleur de sa peau à jeter des doutes
sur la vérité de la véracité de ses
dires
il n'a pas été crue or on sait
aujourd'hui les historiens nous disent
que même s'ils avaient quelque peu
enjolivé son histoire tout n'était pas
faux dans ce qu'il avait affirmé
et au 19e siècle des missionnaires
américains
sont allés en ethiopie pour évangéliser
les peuplades de ces de ces régions là
et dans la province du goddard
ils ont découvert une ethnie très
spécial que les gens du lieu appelé les
falashas
falashas c'est un terme péjoratif
injurieux même est ce que l'on continue
à appeler les falashas n'aime pas du
tout qu'on emploie 7 ce terme en ce qui
les concerne ce sont leurs ennemis qui
employé cette expression pour les
humilier
eux mêmes ce s'appelle les se désigne
sous le nom de beta israel ce qui
signifie la maison d'israël
et ces gens ont affirmé qu' il
descendait de la tribu de dan
c'est très intéressant la tribu de dana
est une des plus petites tribus ce pour
ne pas dire la plus petite des douze
tribus d'israël
et cette tribu
selon une ancienne tradition elle
habitait tout à fait au nord du pays et
elle a été la première à être déportée
elle l'a été avant même que
le reste de restes de la deûle aveux de
l'un des douze tribus soient déportés
parce qu'elle a été déporté non pas par
les assyriens mais par les araméens
et ceux qui ont réussi à échapper à
cette déportation se sont réfugiés en
afrique
et selon cette même tradition
puisque la tribu de dames est la
première des tribus des douze des dix
tribus qui a été déporté même les douze
tribus qui a été déporté au temps de la
fin c'est aussi la première qui
reviendra
et
dont les missionnaires américains vont
coûter cette histoire d'une oreille
intéressée mais sans plus ils n'ont pas
plus fait de cas un certain nombre de
ces gens là se sont convertis au
christianisme d'autres sont restés
fidèles à leur foi israélite et non pas
juive mais il sera inutile bref
on a oublié au 19e siècle parce que j'ai
c'est qu'on a oublié cette histoire de
cette maison d'israël de des confins de
l'ethiopie
deuxième exemple c'est celui de sète au
10e 12e siècle très exactement
c'était à l'époque des croisades
est arrivé sont arrivés aussi en espagne
toujours
deux personnages dont l'un se faisait
appeler
david arrêt ou venez ça veut dire david
de la tribu du ruben et d'autres se
faisait appeler shlomo molkho
salomon mollereau
et ils disaient qu'ils avaient traversé
le sens bayonne qu'ils étaient venus
pour
créer une alliance avec les juifs
d'espagne et éventuellement aussi avec
les chrétiens parce qu'au delà du sens
bayonne il y avait un immense empire
juifs qui existe est extrêmement
puissant et que les croisades qui était
en train de mal finir eh bien on pouvait
connaître un nouvel élan à nouveau
rebondissement si une armée juive une
amie serait lead plus exactement venait
au secours des croisés pour reconquérir
j allais mais la terre sable
et ses deux personnages se sont rendus à
rome pour demander une audience au pape
et nous proposer cette alliance là le
pape a été intéressé par cette histoire
là et la fée venue ces deux personnages
mais quand je suis homo molko ces
programmes est le messie le pape a calé
et il a fait brûler l'un et l'autre
c'est comme ça qu'ils ont fini d'une
manière tragique là aussi les historiens
nous disent que même si l'histoire était
quelque peu enjolivé tout n'était pas
faux dans ce que disait ces deux
personnages là et qu'il y avait entre le
pakistan et l'inde
deux d'entre l'aghanistan le pakistan
excusez moi une passe par laquelle
passent et la route de la soie les roues
grandes routes commerciales qui
commerçait entre l'occident et l'inde il
s'appelle la base de peshawar il y avait
une tribu juive qui contrôlait tout
cette région là et qui prélever une taxe
sur toutes les caravanes qui
franchissait cette passe de peshawar et
les historiens considèrent que
l'expression peshawar signifie passe de
ras bord cette expression qu'on trouve
dans le chapitre 17 du deuxième niveau
des rois que nous avons lu tout à
l'heure
bref
il y avait donc issus des indices
historiques qui montraient qu'ils
montreraient que contrairement à
l'opinion généralement admises les dix
tribus perdues n'avait pas au stand
disparu que non ce que ce que l'on
voulait bien affirmée
et il a fallu attendre
notre temps pour que justement on re
découvre ses dix tribus perdues ces deux
incidents ces deux épisodes que
j'évoquais la ont été oubliés même des
juifs si l'on peut dire et il a fallu
attendre le xxème siècle pour que l'on
veut découvre les dix tribus perdues la
première ça a été la tribu de dan
et en
1973 a eu lieu en ethiopie une
révolution marxiste
l'empereur a été déposée et remplacé par
un gouvernement
communiste
et les troubles qui en ont résulté ont
été attribués aux falashas les falashas
comme tous les juifs où tous les
israélites sont toujours responsables de
tous les malheurs de la création ça
c'est bien connu
et devant la situation difficile dans
laquelle il se trouvait les gens de la
maison d'israël la beta israel se sont
tournés vers le gouvernement israélien
ils ont tenu à peu près ce langage
l'état d'israël a pour vocation
d'accueillir tous les juifs persécutés
du monde ce qui en font la demande nous
ne sommes pas juif mais nous sommes aux
israélites nous sommes vos frères nous
sommes persécutés nous sommes en danger
d'extermination de génocide nous
demandons par conséquent à ça être
accueillis selon sur les bases de la loi
du retour
gouvernement israélien leur a répondu
sèchement dix ans vous n'êtes pas juif
nous ne nous reconnaissons pas comme tel
et par conséquent c'est une fin de non
recevoir que nous vous adressons
bien les choses en sont restées là avec
un certain nombre de difficultés très
grande qu'on connu ces gens de la beta
israel
jusqu'en 1984
1984 nouvelle révolution d'ethiopie
nouveaux troubles dans la province de
kandahar est à nouveau les gens de la
beta israel sont dans une situation
difficile
nouvelles démarches auprès du
gouvernement israélien
cette fois ci il y a à la tête du
gouvernement d'israël un homme qui est
un croyant c'est monsieur menahem begin
et monsieur grighine prend au sérieux la
demande de ces gens là contrairement à
ses prédécesseurs
et il décide de s'adresser aux grands
rabbins d'israël grand rabbin sépharade
en particulier celui s'occupe des
communautés orientales pour savoir si
les dires de ces gens-là quant à leur
origine israélite sont fondées ou non
et c'est ainsi que une délégation
composée de rabbins et d'universitaires
israéliens seront dans la province de
gondar pour enquêter sur l'origine de
ces fameux falashas
et la conclusion de leur enquête est
claire oui
les falashas sont bel et bien des
descendants de la tribu de dames par
conséquent et on a le droit ils ont le
droit d'être à quai en israel sur les
bases de la loi du retour
alors comment faire
le pays est en guerre il n'est pas
question de demander à l'état qui a
rompu tout lien avec avec israël
faciliter la tâche et l'immigration de
ces gens qui sont dans la province du
goddard
finalement on arrive à un accord avec le
gouvernement du soudan
le soudan est un des pays les plus anti
israéliens qu'ils soient si les
musulmans pour ce qui est du nord en
tout cas
et
il est à la tête du combat contre le
sionisme
mais il a besoin d'armes et il a besoin
d'argent
et l'argent n'a pas d'odeur c'est bien
connu et israël propose de financer et
les besoins de l'état soudanais en
argent et en même temps à l'achat
d'armes pour nous que ce même
gouvernement en échange
de quoi le gouvernement soudanais
acceptera que les juifs d'ethiopie
transit sur son territoire et que des
avions israéliens viennent de récupérer
et c'est ainsi qu'en 1984 comment ce
qu'on appelle l'opération salomon
des avions des délais les juifs partent
à pied font plusieurs centaines voire
plusieurs milliers de kilomètres à pied
pour se rendre dans des endroits bien
répertorié au soudan avec la complicité
des autorités soudanaises
et là tout faisait un la nuit des avions
militaires israéliens viennent les
récupérer
la condition bien sûr qu'avec le
gouvernement soudanais pour fermer les
yeux sur cette opération
c'était que ça reste secret il ne répare
étaient
des sens que les pays musulmans
sache que le soudan qui est à la tête du
combat contre l'ennemi sioniste en fait
était en plein compromis avec ce même
ennemi sioniste
et c'est ainsi que plusieurs milliers
environ huit à dix mille
bêta israël ont été transférés du ce2
d'ethiopie jusqu'en israël
et puis en 1984 un journal israélien s
appelle les coudes à a révélé le
pot-aux-roses
est immédiatement le gouvernement
soudanais a mis fin à l'opération
et ça a été une tragédie
parce que ceux qui étaient restés en
ethiopie ne pouvait plus partir
et il y avait des familles qui étaient
divisés des parents qui étaient séparés
leurs enfants des enfants séparés de
leurs parents et il y avait eu aucun
contact aucun compagne contact
épistolaire possible aucun contact
téléphonique possible avec ces gens là
que de toute façon vivaient dans des
conditions
très rudimentaire au point de vue
civilisationnel donc
c'était véritablement une situation
extrêmement dramatique
1991 donc les choses sont restées ainsi
peut-être pour citer un cas que j'ai
connu personnellement
celui d'un jeune homme d'une trentaine
d'années est tenté quelques années qui
s'appelait asher qui
avait un fils de 7 ans
et sa femme était enceinte elle allait
accoucher elle était à terme elle
accoucher d'un nouvel enfant
il avait décidé donc de partir en israël
seulement
la femme qui était enceinte presqu'à
terme il était hors de question pour
elle de faire descendre des centaines de
kilomètres à plus et par conséquent le
couple avait dit c'est la chose suivante
la femme avisée elle son mari tu pars
d'abord avec l'aîné de nos enfants et
quand le bébé sera née juteux
rejoindrait ce qui avait été le cas
seulement entre-temps le couperet de la
guillotine était tombé et les relations
avaient été
brisée entre les deux entre les deux
époux et asher qui se trouvait dans un
kibboutz du nord d'israël les environs
du lac de tibériade
était sans nouvelles de sa femme et de
son enfant ne sais même pas si c'est une
fille ou un garçon qui était né et il
était dans un dans une situation
extrêmement difficile moralement parlant
quand vous pouvez l'imaginer et quand on
l'avait visitée et nous chanter des
chants qu'il avait composé lui-même dans
lesquelles ils exprimaient l'espoir
d'être bientôt rassembler avec sa femme
et son enfant
et plusieurs années ont passé 1991 à
nouveau nouveaux troubles en ethiopie
est à nouveau les juifs sont menacés
cette fois d'extermination les rebelles
marchent sur addis abeba où se sont
rassemblés dans des camps qui dépend de
l'agencé juive les derniers
représentants des falashas et là il ya à
peu près
18 mille falashas qui sont menacés de
mort
le gouvernement israélien
prend contact avec le gouvernement
américain
lequel
réussi à contacter les rebelles et à
l'accord est conclu par l'intermédiaire
du gouvernement des états unis où les
rebelles acceptent moyennant évidemment
aussi bien sûr des rétributions en
argent il accepte de rester l'armé au
pied pendant 72 heures pas une heure de
plus pas une minute de plus 72 heures et
le gouvernement israélien le
gouvernement américain a averti israël
qu'ils ont 72 a pas une de plus pour
évacuer et rapatrions distrait 18000
falashas c'est une gageure
et cette nuit là le téléphone sonne dans
la chambre à coucher de la
directrice d'une agence juive qui
s'appelle madame tsippora lienen et le
mot de code et prononcez le mot de code
est le suivant la prière commence demain
matin ça veut dire que la 72 heures pour
évacuer 78 18000 falashas et cette huile
a des habits les riverains de
l'aérodrome de l'aude qu'elle nous avons
sur lequel nous avons atterri que nous
sommes arrivés et bien
assiste à une opération très spéciale
toute la nuit il entend des avions
militaires qui décolle roues dans roues
les uns après les autres et se disent
c'est une opération militaire majeure
qui est en cours c'était pas vraiment
une opération militaire c'était une
opération humanitaire
et les avions de transport militaires
avaient été réquisitionnés pour aller
récupérer sur les road route d'addis
abeba ces dix-huit mille falashas qui
attendait dans l'envoi ce que l'on peut
imaginer le rapatriement sur la terre
d'israël seulement ces avions là il
avait comme on dit en langage d'aviation
les pattes un peu courte ça veut dire
que il travaillait à la limite de leur
rayon d'action il avait juste une
capacité de transport de kérosène qui
leur permettait d'arriver à addis abeba
directement sans escale ce qui veut dire
que si le pilote faisait la moindre
erreur de navigation dans un sens ou
dans un autre l'avion se crashe et
même en mobilisant toute la flotte de
transport militaire israélienne il était
hors de question de de rapatrier ses du
milf à l'achat alors on a mobilisé les
avions de la compagnie el al
et les avions de la compagnie el al
on a dévissé les sièges notamment des
plus gros avions de transports de
l'époque était le b747 encore appelée
jumbo jet qui peut transporter de 300
environ 300 à 3 400 passagers
avec des sièges davis et ils pouvaient
en apporter environ 1000 donc c'était
évidemment
quelque chose de très important et c'est
ainsi que l'opération
salomon comme on l'appelait a commencé
et c'est du là on a réveillé notre ami
hr dans son kibboutz du nord d'israël
disant voir dépêche toi et un taxi qui
t'attend tu vas rejoindre ta femme et
ton fils tout à fait je vois c'est une
fille la deuxième je suis plus j'ai tout
le monde fait un peu importe ton enfant
du en tout cas et l'autre ne venait pas
dit c'est pas possible et des scènes de
ce type là ce on a rencontré partout
le lendemain
la première page des journaux israéliens
tous les journaux publié l'image d'une
petite fille de 8 ans qui venait de
débarquer d'un des avions et qui était à
genoux pour embrasser la terre d'israël
la piste sur laquelle l'avion venait
d'atterrir
et le nouveau gouvernement israélien a
demandé à tous les citoyens de prendre
part à cette opération là parce que vu
la place limitée qu'il y avait dans les
avions il était hors de question
d'emmener le moindre bagage même un
simple petit sac à main c'était interdit
ronville partait avec tout ce qu'ils
avaient sous la main sur le dos point
final il était mis dans l'avion comme
des sardines en boîte les uns à côté des
autres serrés comme des sardines et il
n'était pas question de bougé d'un
millimètre
et ceux qui ont participé à l'opération
nous ont raconté que il y avait une
discipline exemplaire dans ses pas mis
ces gens là ils attendaient pendant des
heures en plein soleil sans se plaindre
sans s'impatienter pour l'heure facile
de monter dans les avions il entend les
avions les enfants pas un cri pas ou ne
pas pas de pleurs rien du tout ils
étaient 2 d'une sagesse exemplaire
et pendant tout le voyage c'était un
silence qui régnait dans les avions
jusqu'au moment où l'hôtesse les
avertisseurs nisand nous survolons
jérusalem
à ce moment là c'était des explosions
des hurlements de joie
et le gouvernement israélien avait
demandé donc à la population d'amener
des vêtements de la nourriture
il fallait loger rien n'était prévu pour
ça alors on a réquisitionné les grands
hôtels comme celui ci a été visé a été
j'ai rencontré ici d d
et fall h à ker été accueillis dans cet
hôtel dans cet hôtel où nous sommes
il y avait des tonnes de marchandises de
vêtements qui était là devant sur le
devant l'entrée où on ouvrait une
nouvelle liste tout à l'heure et caetera
et on apporte t on à porte etc
je me souviens de sept femmes de rabbins
qui étaient là qui était venue du new
york spécialement pour assister à ça et
qui s'extasiaient sur la manière dont
les isréliens gérer cette affaire là est
un des habitants à des représentations
juive l'a dit madame peut-être qu'un
jour obligé de faire pour vous en
amérique ce que nous sommes en train de
faire pour les falashas bon
plus l'heure fatidique arrive et plus la
tension monte parce qu'il fallait que
les avions face les dernières rotations
et la dernière rotation était celle d'un
jumbo
mais il restait addis abeba
12/100 falashas
et le jumbo même
avec les sièges qui étaient davis et ne
pouvaient emporter que 1000 personnes au
delà de 1000 personnes les ingénieurs de
la boeing avait averti que l'avion
risque est de se cacher
voilà il avait pu le temps matériel de
faire une autre rotation que celle là
c'était l'ultime l'ultime l'ultime
alors il y avait deux solutions
ou bien on sacrifiait 200 personnes qui
restaient sur place et qui était sûr
d'être massacrés par les rebelles
ou bien on prenait le risque d'embarquer
tout le monde avec le risque que les 12
cents personnes et biens soient tués
dans le bain l'accident d'avion qu'est
ce que vous auriez fait
eh bien c'est ce qu'ils ont fait ils ont
tenté le tout plus ils ont tenté le tout
pour le tout mais exactement
le pilote a raconté plus tard que il
avait mis les moteurs de l'avion à
puissance maximum et disait j'ai avalé
jusqu'aux derniers centimètres de la
piste et quand je suis arrivé au bout de
la piste il dit j'ai fermé les yeux jets
privés et puis j'ai tiré sur le manche
et le miracle s'est produit l'avion a
décollé et le voyage s'est bien passé il
a pu atterrir avec ses 12 cents
personnes à bord ça aussi c'était un
miracle
et quand on a raconté ça aux ingénieurs
de la boeing ils ont dit c'est pas vrai
c'est pas possible nous ne dites pas que
vous avez décoller avec 200 personnes à
bord parce qu'à coup sûr avec 200
personnes surcharge pareil vous seriez
crashé en bout de piste
et vous les miracles on a parlé du
miracle hier et les miracles sont
toujours au rendez-vous recettes
financières le peuple d'israël
et c'était à l'heure actuelle les
derniers falashas saisir les soul ap les
fans à choubra ceux qui se sont
convertis au christianisme
reviennent il ya encore quelques-uns qui
ont qui reviennent dans les temps dans
lesquelles nous vivons mais on peut dire
que pratiquement toute la petite tribu
de dan se trouve maintenant rassemblés
dans le pays d'israël c'est la première
des dix tribus perdues qui se trouvent
rassemblés ici et comme la vie du la
tradition que nous avons vu tout ça nous
avons lu tout à l'heure à savoir que
puisque la tribu de dana était la
première tribu qui avait été déporté
elle serait aussi la dernière tribu
qu'arrivé au temps de la fin c'est
exactement ce qui s'est passé
à peu près la même époque il y avait ces
choses allaient marc ben salah ben
eliahou avec rahim qui un jour lisez sa
bible et lisez son livre des psaumes
et l'iab somme qui nous disent aussi
ligue ils allaient ménasché à moi gilad
à moi mais là chut
et il me racontait ceci quand j'ai lu ce
texte que j'avais lu disait-il de
traîneaux très nombreuses reprises que
nous pouvons tous le faire mais
d'issoudun ce jour là c'était comme si
ce texte me sauter à la figure
ça veut dire c'était comme si dieu me
parler personnellement par ceux versés à
moi gilad à moi ménagers
j'ai compris que dieu me demander
d'aller à la recherche de vie la d2
ménasché c'est à dire des dix tribus
perdues
ah oui il me disait j'ai commencé à
discuter avec dieu dix ans c'est bien
gentil seigneur mais ces dix tribus là
elles ont un grave défaut ah oui lequel
elles sont perdues justement
et ladhuie de c'est comme si le seigneur
me disait eh bien elles sont perdues
bâle cherche ni cherché et trouvé je
vais te faire faire en sorte que tu vas
pouvoir les trouver
alors notre ami c'est mieux à la
recherche de ces dix tribus perdues et
était conscient et des essais comme si
dieu m'avait dit je t'ai suscité tu es
venu au monde exactement pour cette
mission là pour aller à la recherche du
tribu perdue c'est le but de ta vie
alors il a commencé par le texte de
deroy 17 que nous avons lu tout à
l'heure
et en même temps
il a pris contact les universitaires
israéliens
et
ces derniers leur ont fourni un texte
des annales des roi d'assyrie
à cette période là nous avons non
seulement les textes bibliques mais nous
avons leurs équivalents à cirer les roi
d'assyrie tenait d une chronique très
très précise de tous leurs actes et
souvent nous avons un parallèle de ce
qui est décrit dans la bible à partir
des annales des roi d'assyrie
il ya des chroniques ou sont relatés
justement cette déportation des dix
tribus du nord dans les annales la
syrienne cette fois ci
et cela confirme la bible à savoir
qu'ils ont été déportés dans ces régions
qui sont évoqués les flots le à ras bord
aa les fleuves de gods and evil 2 mai 10
et cetera et cetera
mais une autre précision contre pas dans
la bible
c'est que qu'a après quelques années de
déportation
les deux tribus du du nord se sont
révoltés à nouveau contre le roi
d'assyrie l'avait se trouvait et non
seulement se sont révoltés maison
entraîner dans le révoltent d'autres
populations du même du même endroit et
le roi d'assyrie a dû mater une révolte
dans cette région là à grand peine
alors quand il a eu une mater la révolte
pour éviter de se trouver devant une
autre situation ce type dans les années
qu'à les suivre il a procédé en ce qui
concerne l et des tribus du nord à une
deuxième déportation
et les annales assuré n 10 qui les a
déporté à une distance considérable
et
convertit les mesures
la série est dans nos mesures modernes
ça fait à peu près 1000 km à l'est de
l'endroit où il se trouvait et dans une
eau dans un endroit 10 des assyriens
montagneux et qui était totalement
inhabitée
le plus grave avait créé la plus une
règle il habille l'extrémité de la règle
sur
l'endroit d'assyrie vous été déportés
les dix tribus et il a tiré un trait à
l'est à 1000 km et s'élevait à elle ça
lui a donné la deuxième ville
d'afghanistan
et il est arrivé à la conclusion que
cette région montagneuse et dépourvu
d'habitants où s'était déporté une
deuxième fois les dix tribus du nord
n'était autre que le coeur même de
l'afghanistan
ravir il était née marie avec une
française grâce à l'ambassade de france
il a pu avoir un passeport français
avec ce passeport français il s'est
rendu en afghanistan
au sein d'une ethnie cela fait beaucoup
parler d'elle dans toutes les guerres
d'afghanistan qui ont marqué ces
dernières années ils s'appellent les
patane
sais pas si vous avez déjà vu des photos
des patins
et bien je ressens comme deux gouttes
d'eau à reading que vous avez au mea
sharim
ils ont la bave maison les périodes
qu'ils ont une coiffure sur la tête on
croirait vraiment qu'on à faire des
juifs
et quand il est arrivé là bas le havre
il a été très étonné ces gens leur ont
dit oui
officiellement nous sommes musulmans
mais en réalité nous sommes
des descendants de la tribu de ménager
et il a pu avoir des preuves il y avait
des musées aux autres c'est plus têtus
et qu'ils y apportent des maisons avec
les rouleaux de la torah
avec lesquels dans lesquelles il y avait
des rouleaux de la torah mais écrite ont
vieilli breux en hébreu de l'époque du
premier tank
que les patates moderne et est incapable
de lire mais il reproduisait fidèlement
quand même il avait la circoncision à 8
jours et non pas à 13 ans comme les
musulmans il allumé des bougies le
vendredi soir pour le shabbat
il célébrer la pâque en sacrifiant un
boeuf et non pas un mouton parce que les
moutons n'est pas connue là-bas il mais
tel est le sens sur les linteaux des
portes et sur les poteaux des maisons
bref il y avait un tout un ensemble de
coutumes biblique qui montrait que ces
gens là avaient une culture biblique et
tous les ans à la fête de pâques il
avait des prêtres qui les rassemblait et
le grand prêtre dssi écoute israël tu es
ménasché le fils de jacob il raconté
toute l'histoire de la tribu
oui oui ça commence à être connu pendant
et ces gens là où dit écoutez vous êtes
un envoyé du ciel parce que nous avons
l'intention de revenir dans notre pays
dû revenir dans le pays d'israël
et de la donc le rav avihaï il a
poursuivi sa route et s'est rendu dans
d'autres
dispersion d'autres diaspora des fils de
ménager au cachemire au pakistan et en
inde dans l'état du mizoram en
particulier où il y avait aussi des
descendants de la tribu de ménage et
attributs d'une hache et était avec sa
tribu d'iframe la plus grande des dix
tribus perdues
et quand il est revenu en israël et qui
l'a révélé cela ça a été un scandale
abominable
comment parce que là ça couvre tout ça
que ça concerne et dé plusieurs millions
de personnes
le gouvernement israélien du mais c'est
hors de question que nous recevions ces
gens là on a déjà pas de place pour
mettre les juifs qui sont rapatriés de
russie deux des tuyaux plus
de l'ukraine et d'autres endroits
qu'est-ce que vous voulez qu'on fasse de
ces millions de personnes dont on n'est
même pas sûr d'ailleurs qu'il soit
véritablement des descendants des tribus
perdues c'est vous qui le dites mais on
n'a aucune preuve que c'est la vérité
et ça a été un non catégorique qui a été
accordée à ces demandes duras de ravir
et hilde et lui-même a été traîné dans
la boue dans la presse pourra avoir osé
justement affirmé qu'on avait
redécouvert les dix tribus perdues
les dix tribus perdues on les a
maintenant retrouvé à peu près tout
et elles sont maintenant bien
répertoriée à laz où je vous parle on
sait exactement où se trouvent toutes
les 10 et comme le disait la tradition
elles sont situées entre la maison pota
me salir le fleuve de l'euphrate qui est
vraisemblablement le
lui avec le fleuve de gotham et puis
jusque en chine hélas le désuet six tirs
israéliens qui sont allés aussi là bas
en afghanistan dans des conditions un
peu secrète
ont rapporté des preuves archéologiques
de la présence des dix tribus perdues en
afghanistan et ils sont allés à la
conclusion que le peuplement
de l'afghanistan la base la population
de l'afghanistan ce sont des tribus
perdues il faut dire que la plupart des
afghans ont du sens israélites dans les
veines
c'était vraiment combler ce que parce
que l'afghanistan est une est un des
pays les plus anti israéliens qu'ils
soient en pourtant beaucoup sont des
descendants des tribus perdues après ça
sont devenus d'autres populations du
sont venus d'autres endroits qui se sont
mélangées avec cela mais la base du
peuplement c'est celui là et il a des
preuves absolument indiscutable
d'ailleurs afghanistan c'est un cétacé
c'est un mot hébreu ccdh us est lié avec
la langue hébraïque
et 2 donc le problème était le suivant
recoller en duel le spécialiste de la
question si professeur la vie dure
sharan qui habitent ici à natanya
les reconstituer ce qui était l'épopée
des dix tribus perdues à partir du
moment où ils ont été rassemblés en
afghanistan ils n'ont eu qu'un seul but
c'est de revenir dans le pays promet
seulement revenu par l'ouest c'était
hors de question
pascal emplira syrien avait succédé dans
babylon hien puis empire perse puis l
empire d'alexandre le grand puis ensuite
les parts et c'est donc il y avait des
grands empires qui rendait tout par
l'ouest absolument impossible mais comme
tous les lecteurs de la bible les
descendants des tribus ce avec la terre
est ronde
parce que c'est ce que la bible dit
et sont ici ne pouvons pas passer par
l'ouest nous pouvons passer par l'est en
faire le tour de la terre
et là
ils pensaient revenus par l'afrique par
le sénégal et du sénégal donc
par terre cette fois-ci assez jusque en
dans le pays serait la seule chose
qu'ils ignoraient c'est que il y avait
de l'amérique entre ces deux continents
là
mais néanmoins et se sont mis en marche
et il ya eu deux colonnes qui sont
parties de l'afghanistan en direction de
l'est
une première colonne qui a suivi un
fleuve qui s'appelle le fleuve de
l'amou-daria qui sonne le professeur
chan serait le flop de lausanne dont il
est question dans le texte que nous
avons lu l'amou-daria c'est un fleuve
très très long
qui c'est qui sert de frontière entre le
l'afghanistan le pakistan le cachemire
l'inde et la chine ensuite se jette dans
la mer de chine
avec les anciennes républiques
musulmanes de l'ex urss
et c'est ainsi que les représentants de
ces tribus perdues sont arrivés au bord
de la mer de chine
et là ils se sont embarqués ils ont
atterri au japon
le japon et quand ils sont arrivés là
bas ils ont pensé qu'ils étaient arrivés
en afrique c'était le sénégal
il aura fallu assez peu de temps pour se
rendre compte de leur erreur
qu'elle a de réaliser qu entre le japon
et le
le sénégal il y avait une grande flaque
d'eau a traversé sera coupé l'appétit
et ceux restés sur place
et il y à toute une partie de la
population japonaise qui s'est marié
avec des descendants des tribus perdues
de telle sorte que dans la culture
japonaise il y a non seulement dans la
langue japonaise des mots hébreu mais
même dans la culture japonaise il ya
beaucoup de coutume israélite qui sont
qui sont introduites dans
toutes les coutumes les traditions et
c'était là et même l'histoire certains
descendants des tribus perdues sont tous
devenus des empereurs du japon
d'autres sont revenus ils ont participé
à la construction de la grande muraille
de chine et à l'heure actuelle les
premiers descendants de ces juifs la
halle de ceis rhinite là reviennent en
israël au moment où je vous parle
et il ya une autre branche qui elle est
partie en direction du sud et du sud est
en direction de la birmanie de et en fin
de compte qui a attiré encore et qui est
sûr sûr sûr la route est bien un certain
nombre se sont arrêtés dans un empire
mondial à la frontière de la birmanie
l'inde et la chine
et pour former une ethnie qui fait
encore un peu parler d'elle de temps en
temps en 20e page de votre journal en
bas de page c'est ce qu'on appelle les
carènes
les karens ont une ethnique est
persécutée par les musulmans et qui
se bat pour sa survie dans des
conditions extrêmement difficiles dans
l'indifférence la plus générale bien
entendu puisque ils sont pas musulmans
et son contraire combattu par des
musulmans or les carènes sont des
chrétiens et des chrétiens qui ont été
évangélisé par le grand missionnaire
britannique du 19e siècle qui s'appelait
de l'iram johnson elle ira du sun
raconte dans ses mémoires quand il est
arrivé avec son équipe missionnaire chez
les karens et derniers les ont reçus
comme des anges de dieu
et
ils étaient très étonnés mais
et ces gens l'ont dit nous sommes en
fait des descendants des tribus perdues
et quand nous sommes partis de notre
pays nous avions à la livre que dieu
nous avait donné c'était le livre de
dieu
mais à cause de nos péchés nous l'avons
perdu ce livre là
et dieu nous a dit eh bien
c'est effectivement votre châtiment
votre jugement mais autant de la fin des
hommes blancs vous ramèneront ce livre
et les missionnaires demandé mais est-ce
que vous avez une petite idée de ce
qu'ils pouvaient avoir dans ce livre
paru de raconter l'histoire la création
l'histoire du déluge histoire la tour de
babel l'histoire de l'appel d'abraham
de l'histoire de joseph et cetera
l'exode et l'émission dit ce serait pas
ce livre quelquefois mais oui mais bien
sûr on dit résorber oui mais c'est savez
vous êtes les envoyés de dieu
c'est ainsi que et se sont convertis au
christianisme
la plupart d'entre eux sans oublier
leurs origines israélite et sans
renoncer à l'espoir de revenir dans le
pays premier autant de la faim
aujourd'hui le gaz que vous n'y a que
quelques karen qui sont venus dans le
pays d'israël
parce que les rabbins vu qu'ils sont
chrétiens la plupart d'entre eux
font tout pour les empêcher d'arriver
mais
le désir est là
et puis de là ils ont continué en
direction de la corée et il ya encore et
aussi des descendants des tribus perdues
alors c'est plus desquels
les distribuer et là ils se sont
embarqués aussi tout ce qu'ils pensaient
être l'afrique depuis la corée et même
chose ils sont arrivés au japon tout en
pensant que c'était le sénégal
et la même chose les deux branches sont
rassemblés et puis
non pas n'ont pas poussé plus loin se
disant qu'il y avait rien d'autre chose
à faire qu'à attendre la venue du messie
pour pouvoir rassembler dans la terre
promise mais sans jamais perdre l'espoir
de l'être véritablement
serait intéressant de noter que dans les
chapitres 49,2 livre du prophète isaïe
et les questions de ceux qui reviennent
de loin nous at il dit
et notamment qui reviennent du pays de
cynisme
si nîmes sète au verset clan chapitre 49
versée
je vous le retrouver
non peu importe je ne trouve pas si
simple de 49 en tout cas vous le
retrouverez je les ramènerais du pays de
cynisme si nîmes ça veut dire la chine
en hébreu
est actuellement c'est ce qui est en
train se produire les des familles
juives de chine sont en train de revenir
dans le pays premier
calcul est décédé il ya deux ou trois
ans de cela il me disait de toute
manière notre tradition nous dit ceci
c'est que nous allons amorcer la pompe
si j'ose dire
et c'est m6 qui va terminer le travail
nous nous allons le but c'est que lui et
des représentants des dix tribus perdues
dans le pays d'israël qu'on aimait ci
reviendra puis après le bain lui se
débrouillera avec ça ce sera son
problème ce sera plus notre
or
lever la contrainte du gouvernement
israélien c'est d'être submergés sous le
nombre de ces gens qui arrivent quand
j'en ai parlé aux arabes avaient failli
je vous dis
c'est une seule un problème qui est un
problème réel ou est-ce que vous allez
mettre tous ces gens s'ils veulent
revenu il m'a dit écoute ta qali zachary
il ya quelque chose qui dit à ce sujet
la
verser
zakeri 10 verset 10 je les ferai revenus
du pays d'égypte je les rassemblerai de
la syrie je les frères à venir au pays
de guilad est relié au liban alors le
gilad s'est on est passé devant tout à
l'heure c'est la jordanie pauvre petit
roi abdallah
et le liban
voyez-vous autant de la fin
le liban sera aussi inclus dans les
frontières d'israël et sera appelée à
accueillir une partie de ces gens qui
reviendront et même ainsi
l'espace de leur suffira pas
dit le texte
même ainsi
alors j'ai dit aux abeilles mais c'est
pas une réponse c'est pas une solution
mais ça c'est pas mon problème
encore une fois mon problème
c'est de faire en sorte qu'il y ait
quand même si viendra essayer des
représentants de chacune des dix tribus
et puis le reste c'est au messie qui
s'allongera avec ça ce sera plus mon
problème à moi
iriez-vous il a dit ceci que c'est très
important
pendant que aura lieu ce retour des dix
tribus perdues le messie viendra c'est
le dernier signe avant la venue du
messie et nous sommes en train de vivre
ce grand seront autour des dix tribus
perdues ce retour il est en cours et par
conséquent nous pouvons être certains
que le messie peut venir à tout moment
un dernier un dernier point avant de
plus de terminer une question qui se
pose est la suivante est-ce que le
nouveau testament croit au retour des
dix tribus perdues
alors
je voudrais dire un texte dans
l'évangile de luc au chapitre 21
alors au chapitre 23
temps et non
c'est de retrouver
ses biens le plus chapuis soit 21 ans
j'avais 22 par an voilà
[Musique]
c'est le soir de pâques
où
jésus donc prend la dernière peut
reparler ses disciples et il éclate une
dispute entre les disciples pour savoir
qui est le plus grand
et
jésus le réponse de répond que le plus
grand c'est celui qui sera le plus
humble plus petit pas mieux et il dit
ceci au verset 20 c'est pourquoi je
dispose le royaume pour vous comme mon
père on a disposé pour moi afin que vous
mangez que vous buviez à ma table dans
mon royaume et que vous sans jouer assis
sur des trônes pour juger
les douze tribus d'israël
et oui les douze tribus ce qui veut dire
que jésus croyez aux vautours des dix
tribus perdues
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
ils avaient établi douze apôtres
patrese
panne pas 10 à 11
et quand il y en a un qui a disparu
comme on le sait judas qui s'est suicidé
après la crucifixion
les apôtres ont éprouvé le besoin de luz
de lui désigner un successeur pour que
le collège des 12 soit complet pourquoi
nous
sommes ici dans notre texte pour que
vous soyez assis sur des troupes dans
mon royaume pour juger les douze tribus
stress jugé par langage publiques ça
veut dire gouverner par exemple livre
des juges est juste et pas simplement
des gens qui ont des fonctions
judiciaires sont des gens qui ont aussi
des fonctions de leader militaire et
d'une vigueur politique également
et par conséquent les douze seront les
chefs des douze tribus
quand le peuple d'israël sera rassemblé
autant de la fin
nous n'oublierons pas deux autres textes
mais je déciderai simplement
apocalypse chapitre 7
où il est question de 144 milles
représentants de douze tribus d'israël
je vais pas entrer dans la question de
savoir qui sont ces 144 milles qui ont
fait la fortune certaines sectes que je
ne nommerai pas le fond de commerce mais
ce que je voudrais retenu ici c'est
qu'il est question aussi de
représentants des douze tribus donc le
livre de l'apocalypse lui aussi croit au
retour des douze tribus et enfin
apocalypse 21 et 22 la nouvelle
jérusalem où
la nouvelle jérusalem anosy porte avec
12 fondement
et
sur le nom sur les chacune des portes de
la ville est écrit le nom d'une des
douze tribus d'israël
et sur les fonds demandés portent le nom
d'un des douze apôtres de l'agneau ça
veut dire que à chacune des douze tribus
d'israël que nous vous trouvons dans la
nouvelle jérusalem est associé un apôtre
qui vraisemblablement en est le leader
donc ici le nouveau testament lui aussi
croire au retour d'éditer des tribus
perdues
envoyez vous combien comme jésus disait
à ses disciples il pourrait devenir
aussi l' homme sans intelligence lents à
comprendre et à croire ce qu'ont annoncé
les prophètes je disais tout à l'heure
que beaucoup de chrétiens évangéliques
eu du mal à croire pour le tour des dix
tribus
pourquoi parce que il ya cette idée
qu'ils ont disparu qui se sont assimilés
et en fait nous voyons que ils se sont
pas véritablement assimilé il ya un
texte d'ailleurs dans l'eau et qui nous
dit cela ephraim inbar abitbol belle
baie amim ça veut dire
comment ce qu'on peut traduire ephraim
s'assimile mais c'est pas le mot exact
ça veut dire ils s'assimilent en
apparence
pouces préserver son existence il fait
mine de s'assimiler
mais il cache ans quelle que soit son
origine
mais il la conserve
et le rav avihaï il a découvert aussi ce
texte
houdan jeremie 31 il dit ceci
reste issing
mais des poteaux indicateurs
en gardant la route du pass
revient vient jeu d'israël et non pas de
judas revient dans ces villes qui sont à
toi
et l'explication des singes et sereine
et celle ci
jusqu'au temps de la fin les dix tribus
perdues ont caché leurs origines pour
pouvoir survivre c'est une question de
survie question de vie ou de mort
et par conséquent on aura l'impression
qu'elles ont disparu mais quand viendra
le temps de la fin le missile de redire
à maintenant dresse décimer des poteaux
indicateurs ne cache plus ce que tu es
affiche toi au grand jour
et montre que tu es prêt à revenir dans
le pays promet
aujourd'hui c'est exactement ce que tu
es en train de se passer nous en train
de vue l'accomplissement de ces
prophéties projet m'arrêter là mais en
conclusion je dirai simplement ici nous
vivons un temps de miracle
extraordinaire et pour moi ce retour des
tribus perdues est un des plus grand
miracle que nous sommes en train de
vivre je le suis d'ailleurs très très
d'une manière très très précises depuis
des années maintenant
parce que pour moi c'est vraiment un des
grands signes des temps de la fin un des
grands signes de la proximité de la
venue du messie voilà ce que je voulais
vous dire ce soir et sera le suivant la
torah dans le sermon sur la montagne
j'aimerais qu'on dise quelques versets
dans l'évangile de matthieu chapitre 5 à
partir dû verser 17
c'est juju qui parient dit je ne pensais
pas que je sois venu pour abolir la
torah ou des prophètes je suis venu non
pas pour abolir mais pour accomplir en
vérité je vous le dis jusqu'à ce que le
ciel et la terre passe pas un seul viau
t'as pas un seul trait de lettres de la
torah ne passeras jusqu'à ce que tout
cela ne soit arrivé
celui donc qui violera l'un de ces plus
petits commandement et qui enseignera
aux hommes de faire de même se rappeler
le plus petit dans le royaume des cieux
celui qui nous mettra en pratique des
enseignements à celui là sera appelée
grand dans le royaume des cieux car je
vous le dis si votre justice n'est pas
supérieure à celle des scribes et des
pharisiens vous n'entrerez pas dans le
royaume de dieu
précieux pardon vous avez entendu qu'il
a été dit aux anciens tu ne commettras
pas de meurtre celui qui commet un
meurtre il sera passible de jugement
mais moi je vous dis quiconque se met en
colère contre son frère sera passible du
jugement celui qui lisent à son frère
aka sera justice justiciables du
sanhédrin celui qui nous dira un sens et
sera passé de la jeune du feu si donc tu
présentes en offrande à l'hôtel et que
tu te souviennes que ton frère a quelque
chose contre toi laisse la tong au front
devant l'hôtel et va d'abord réconcilier
avec ton frère plus vient présenter ton
offrande à enjeu tout affrontement avec
ton adversaire pendant que tu es encore
en chemin avec lui tu eu peur que
l'adversaire ne te livre juge le juge
garde qu'une famille en prison en vérité
je te le dis tu ne sortiras pas de là je
sais ce que tu es payé jusqu'au dernier
centime
il y a à la fois dans le christianisme
dans le judaïsme
l'idée que jésus a aboli la torah
et
c'est quelque chose qui est tellement
ancrée dans les mentalités que quand on
lit ce texte et bien c'est quelque chose
qui gêne
parce que comme me disait comme le
disait le professeur nouveau testament
quand j'étais étudiant ici à
l'université à jérusalem est est le
professeur david ferrer qui était un
juif orthodoxe
aucun sage d'israël n'a fait en faveur
de la torah des affirmations aussi
absolue que celle que nous trouvons ici
dans la bouche de jésus au travers des
quelques versets que nous avons lu
alors comment comprendre cette
opposition
qui veut que je une est aboli la torah
jésus pouvait-il abolir la torah
s'il avait fait qui se serait placé ipso
facto en marge du judaïsme
s'il l'avait fait il aurait été
considéré comme un faux prophète
est en effet
un texte dans le livre du deutéronome
chapitre 18 qui dit ceci ce il surgit au
milieu de toi un prophète qui enseignent
autre chose que ce qui a été enseigné
par moïse et bien tu ne l'écoutera pas
c'est dieu qui te met à l'épreuve ce
sera un faux prophètes
et c'est une des raisons pour lesquelles
le judaïsme considère le christianisme
comme une hérésie comme une fausse
prophétie
parce que précisément on pense que jésus
a aboli la torah
peut pas en tenir compte en tenir
rigueur
à nos amis juifs
parce que en général dans nos milieux
chrétiens c'est ce que nous professons
pouvons pas demander aux juifs d'être
plus chrétiens que les chrétiens
forcément et par conséquent si nous
enseignons que jésus a aboli la torah
juifs n'ont aucune raison de le mettre
en doute
et c'est une des raisons de la
séparation entre les deux religions
le judaïsme considère le christianisme
comme une religion étrangère parce que
précisément on a fait table rase on a
fait abstraction de la torah
alors il ya ce texte il est très gênant
très gênant pour
asseoir cette idée que jésus a aboli la
torah il s'en défend et avec quelle
vigueur ne croyez pas que je sois venu
pour abolir la torah et les prophètes je
suis venu pour un bonus non pas pour à
venir mais pour acompte
nous allons voir que ce sont deux termes
qui sont des termes spécifiques du
vocabulaire
religieux juifs desquels du vocabulaire
des rabbins mais comment ce tir ton de
ce mauvais pas alors par des acrobaties
intellectuelles absolument
extraordinaires
ont reconnu que jésus a bel et bien
respecté la torah et qu'il a accompli
tout ce qui était écrit dans la torah
mais nous dit-on 7 afin
que nous soyons dispensés nous de
l'accomplir puisque jésus accomplit la
torah nous nous sommes dispensés
d'accomplir la torah prend fin avec lui
elle est un autre terme que une autre
expression qu'on trouve dans l'épître
aux galates que l'on emploie dans le
même sens le messie jésus et la fin de
la torah
dont il met fin à la torah en oubliant
que le mot telle hausse en grec s'il
peut signifier effectivement à la fin
d'une réalité d'une chose mais aussi le
but l'intention
est dans le contexte des gars là tu sais
le sens que paul donne à ce texte là il
est l'intention même de la torah nom qui
ne met pas fin à la torah origines de la
torah du tout
et il y à une autre une autre expression
qu'on trouve également pour essayer de
justifier le fait que jésus ait mis fin
à la régime de la torah même si pour lui
même il a respecté la torah jusque dans
les plus petits détails
c'est quand il était sur la croix et là
donc il
il cite dans une des paroles de la
croyais de dernière parole de la croix
avant qu'ils ne meurent et celle ci tout
est accompli
donc tout est accompli sa veux dire
toute la torah est accomplie et par
conséquent il n'est plus du tout
nécessaire pour le chrétien de respecter
la torah puisque christ a accompli la
torah et il a mis fin au régime de la
torah donc dans en particulier sur la
croix
là aussi il ya un problème de traduction
le terme grec et le suivante et les
détails et on retrouve la même racine
que dans le mode et lorsque j'évoquais
tout à l'heure il est la fin de la torah
c'est à dire le but
est là aussi il est question d'un but
tout est accompli ça veut dire le but a
été atteint
le but pour lequel je suis venu sur la
terre a été atteint
c'est le sens du mot
et par conséquence rien à voir avec une
remise en question de la torah ou non
remise en question de la torah
autre objection que l'on a pour
essayer de démontrer que la torah n'est
plus de mise pour le chrétien c'est
l'épître aux hébreux où il est question
de l'ancienne alliance qui est en train
de passer
mais l'ancienne alliance que nous qui
est opposé à la nouvelle alliance sa
nouvelle alliance c'est celle qui dont
il est question dans le livre du
prophète jérémie au chapitre entier à
verser 31 là où il est dit pas si les
gens viennent je ferai avec la maison
d'israël avec la maison du judas une
alliance nouvelle
ce que l'épître aux hébreux veut nous
dit l'auteur des pièces aux hébreux veut
nous dire ce n'est pas que la torah ce
que nous appelons nous l'ancien
testament est abolie
mais que le régime des sacrifices va
cesser
et comme beaucoup de contemporains
l'auteur de l'épître aux hébreux est
parfaitement conscient que les jours du
temple sont comptés et que le temple
risquent d'être détruits nous sommes ici
à la fin années 50 début des années 60
le temple risque de disparaître et par
conséquent le culte anciens le culte qui
était le culte énergétique risque de
devenir impossible donc il faut trouver
autre chose et ça c'est exactement la
même démarche que celle qu'on trouve
dans le talmud qui considère que le
temple étant détruits on ne peut plus
offrir des sacrifices dans le temple
donc il faut ré interpréter les lois de
la torah pour les appliquer au contexte
nouveau que le contexte de l'exil et la
visée de l'auteur de l'épître aux
hébreux est exactement la même elle ne
fait qu'anticiper ce que le talmud
annoncera plus tard mais c'est
fondamentalement la même démarche donc
revenons à notre texte
on ne peut pas donc ici trouver
véritablement de texte qui laisse
entendre que jésus a aboli la torah et
lui-même encore une fois s'en défend je
ne suis pas venu pour à bonnut je suis
venu pour accomplir
bien
ces paroles de jésus ne sont pas venus
en grec parce que le nouveau testament
ne vous est pas venu dans cette langue
mais tous les commentateurs sont
d'accord pour reconnaître que jésus n'a
pas prononcé ces paroles en grec tes
paroles originales de jésus n'était pas
dite en grec elles ont été traduites
pour les besoins justement des lecteurs
de langue grecque
et on pense c'était en tout cas ce que
pense et mon professeur nouveau
testament professeur fou serre on pense
que en fait jésus par les hébreux
l'hébreu de qumran c'était brute que
l'on dit n'a découvert dans les fameux
manuscrits de la mer morte qui est un
hébreu qui était tout à fait inconnu qui
n'est ni l'hébreu du de la bible ni
l'hébreu biblique classique ni l'hébreu
de l'époque de la mishna c'est à dire
après la destruction du temple c'est un
hébreu tout à fait particulier en hébreu
qu'on ne connaissait pas que l'on
appelle pour cette raison les bruits de
qumran et qui était vraisemblablement
l'hébreu qui étaient parlées en judée
pendant les périodes la période du
nouveau testament et même si la ramée à
semble-t-il était aussi parlé dans le
pays d'israël
il est tout ce qui était officielle et
notamment l'enseignement de la bible se
faisait ton hébreu l'araméen été
conservé et est utilisé essentiellement
pour la vie courante
donc ici il nous faut traduire les
paroles de jésus en hébreu et si vous
réduisez les paroles de jésus au début
je ne suis pas venu pour abolir je suis
venu pour accomplir ça vous donne je
suis pas venu pour alors on est beau et
du laid va-t-elle mais pour accomplir
les cas m
et ça ce sont des expressions techniques
du vocabulaire à binic
les va-t-elle ça veut dire donner une
explication une interprétation erronée
du commandement
si vous donnez une interprétation
erronée du commandement automatiquement
vous labo lycée
mais si vous en donner une explication
juste alors vous le confirmez vous
l'établissent et et c'est exactement ce
que jésus veut dire
et le message de jésus jésus se défend
dans son message qui va devenir
l'évangile de se positionner en
opposition avec la torah
avec la torah de moïse en particulier
d'ailleurs c'est très intéressant de
noter que
jésus dans le sermon sur la montagne va
qu'augmenter
que la torah de moïse et notamment les
dix paroles et plus spécifiquement la
deuxième table des dix paroles vous
savez qu'il y à deux tables de la torah
de table de dix paroles et sur chaque
table il ya cinq commandements 5,5
parole puisque il ya en fait que neuf
commandement la première des dix paroles
étant une promesse je suis l'éternel ton
dieu tu devais sortir du pays d'egypte
et de la maison des esclaves
par conséquent
il ya cinq
parole sur la première table et 5 parole
sur la deuxième table
et les paroles de la première table sont
les devoirs que l'homme doit rendre
envers dieu
tandis que la deuxième table ce sont les
paroles que l'on doit à réaliser
accomplir vis-à-vis du prochain
et
il y avait à l'époque de jésus une
manière
disons assez particulière de résumer ces
deux tables
la première des tables je les dis
concernés les devoirs que le croyant
à envers dieu
et cela se confirme ce se concrétise
par un autre commandement qu'ils
trouvent dans le schéma israël et qu
israël était attendue est un dieu un tu
aimeras le seigneur ton dieu de tout ton
coeur de tout ton âme de tout à force et
de tout à penser tu aimeras le seigneur
ton dieu
et jésus résumera la torah aussi de
cette manière là quand il sera interrogé
par un docteur de la loi qui lui demande
quel est le plus grand des commandements
et jésus le site le schéma écoute israël
tu aimeras le seigneur ton dieu de tout
ton coeur de tout ton âme
le tout à penser
et il ajoute et voici le second qui lui
est semblable tu aimeras ton prochain
comme toi-même de ces deux commandements
dépendent toute la torah et les
prophètes
par conséquent on résumer la torah
par simplement le fait d'aimer tu es ma
première table tu aimeras l'éternel ton
dieu
deuxième table tu aimeras ton prochain
comme toi même
et par conséquent
il y a une manière disons de comprendre
toute la torah
ça veut dire de la ramener à l'essentiel
et
l'application des commandements cette
application qui est prescrite par jésus
lui-même on l'a vu il ne disparaîtra pas
un seul iota et un seul trait de l'être
jusqu'à ce que tout soit accomplie et là
aussi c'est très intéressant parce que
nous avons vu justement ce texte que
l'on applique pour essayer de montrer
que jésus a aboli la torah tout est
accompli
tout est accompli tout est accompli à
partir du moment où jésus rend l'âme sur
la croix
or que nous dit jésus ici dans cette est
aussi longtemps que le ciel et la terre
subsisteront qui ne disparaîtra pas de
la torah un seul iota et un seul trait
de l'être
à votre avis est ce que le ciel et la
terre existe encore aujourd'hui
c'est même pas la peine de poser la
question
s'il en est ainsi tous les commandements
de la torah sont encore valables
aujourd'hui deux mille ans après la mort
de jésus
c'est c'est un indiscutable c'est
imparable
et on trouve
chose de semblable chez un un scribe
qui se nommera biche à el
arish mail et escribe et ce qu'est ce
que c'est qu'un ce crible c'était
quelqu'un qui copié qui copient encore
et encore des scribes aujourd'hui qui
copilote entre autres la torah
vous savez que dans une synagogue je ne
sais pas si simple qu'elle ne savait pas
je vous l'apprends dans une synagogue on
ne peut pas faire la lecture de la torah
à partir d'un texte imprimé un texte cri
comme je le sais ce texte ici vous
l'avez tous on appelle un livre nous
pour nous c'est un livre un livre cd
pages que l'on tourne et en fait les
spécialistes appellent ceux du genre de
livre là un codex
or on n'a pas le droit de lire la torah
à partir d'un codex dans la synagogue on
doit la lire sur des rouleaux de pages
de lui deux de peau de bête
qui sont écrites à la main selon une
tradition ancestrale qui remonte dans la
nuit des temps
et depuis des temps les plus aimés morio
il y avait des hommes dont la fonction
était justement de copier la torah
selon des règles d'ailleurs extrêmement
précises qui subsistent encore
aujourd'hui pour s'assurer de la
fidélité de la transmission du texte
ensuite le texte été révisé par un autre
un autre scribe qui s'assurer qu'il n'y
avait pas de fautes que tu écris et tu
es passé s'il en avait s'il y en avait
été immédiatement corrigée et cetera
cède encore comme ça que l'on possède de
nos jours et c'est ce qui nous a valu
d'avoir un texte fiable jusqu'à
aujourd'hui on a un texte fiable de la
torah comme l'ont montré par exemple les
découvertes de qumrân
par conséquent rabhi schmele était ce
crible
et en général jusqu'à nos jours
d'ailleurs aussi c'est toujours comme ça
que ça se produit à fonction de scribe
est une fonction qui se transmet de père
en fils
et quant à bichat elle a senti sa mort
venue il a fait venir son fils
qui devait lui succéder dans cette tâche
il a donné ses dernières recommandations
lui a dit monfils après inscription sur
dix aussi mon fils soit très méticuleuse
soit très soigneux dans le travail que
tu vas faire
n'ajoute aucune lettre et ne retranche
aucune
car elles contiennent les lettres de la
torah elles contiennent le monde entier
comparez cette parole du rabbi jumelles
avec la parole de jésus aussi longtemps
que le ciel et la terre passeront ne
disparaîtra pas un seul iota et un seul
trait de l'être jusqu'à ce que tout soit
accompli et il ya cette idée dans le
judaïsme que dans d'abord dieu a
créé le monde
à partir de là tu auras ta tora et est
une réalité qui préexistait à la
création est en elle est contenue et le
plan de l'univers tel qu'il existe de
nos jours le tri sorte que dans la torah
ya tous les secrets de l'univers
évidemment il faut savoir la livre
savoir déchiffrer c'est secret là c'est
pas à la portée de n'importe qui mais
c'est possible
et c'est la raison pour laquelle
comme le dit jésus ici pas un seul trait
de l'être pas un seul iota la plus
petite des lettres de l'alphabet
hébraïque ude pas un seul trait de
lettres cesser ces augmentations qu'il
ya sur certaines lettres que les scribes
retransmettre en souscrive soigneusement
même si ils ne comprennent pas toujours
la signification mais c'est dans le
texte le texte original allons leur
produit calculé parce qu'il ya là des
secrets qui concerne des choses qu'ils
sont
cachés aux roses aux roses aux yeux des
êtres humains et qui seront peut-être
que voulait un jour quand le seigneur
estimons que cela soit donc il n'y rien
ne peut disparaître jusqu'à ce que le
ciel et la terre disparaissent le même
parce que précisément c'est à cause de
la torah que le monde entier a pu être
créée
donc il y a dans la torah
des commandements
et des commandements que jésus appelle
ici petits et grands en fait ça c'est
aussi une traduction grecque de 2000
breux et il faudrait traduire
vraisemblablement
cette expression petit commandement ou
grands commandements par commandement
lourds ou commandement léger ce sont
aussi des catégories disons du
vocabulaire rabbinique
un commandement lourd
c'est par exemple celui que nous avons
vu tout à l'heure
tu ne commettras pas de meurtre
bon et bien évident que commettre un
meurtre
trucider son prochain c'est pas une
affaire banale c'est pas une petite
affaire c'est quelque chose d'infiniment
grave ou quelque chose de lourd
et le problème est le suivant
qu'est ce qui peut amener un être humain
à vouloir trucider son prochain c'est
quand même pas chose naturelle c'est pas
quelque chose qui n'est tous les jours
c'est pas tous les jours qu'on a envie
de tuer son prochain et qu'on le fait
est bien qu'est ce qui peut provoquer
une telle dérive une telle démarche
abominable
la colère la jalousie le ressentiment la
haine que l'on peut avoir pour son
prochain
est comme gelée l'ont fait les sages
jésus ici met en garde il dit
tu peux penser
que
jamais tu ne viendras le commandement
lors
que jamais tu ne tueras ton prochain une
commettra de meurtre sur la personne de
ton prochain
mais est ce que tu en es sûr oui bien
sûr j'ai su ça a jamais jamais je ne
porterais la main sur mon prochain
sauf si tu laisses dans ton coeur
rentrée de la haine sur ton prochain si
tu nourris cette haine c'est une wii la
rend la rancune si tu nourris la colère
et si tu laisses ses sentiments mauvais
entrer dans ton coeur qui te dis qu'un
jour tu ne vas pas passé à l'acte
même à ton corps défendant même sans
l'avoir cherché
vous savez en tant que pasteur et nous
arrive parfois de visiter des
prisonniers en prison des criminels qui
sont condamnés à des 20 ans 30 ans de
prison pour meurtre c'est quand on parle
avec ces gens là et qu'ils me font des
confidences certains vous diront ceux ci
je sais pas ce qui m'a pris c'était plus
fort que moi et
je les tue et je les tuer et puis quand
je les fais j'ai regretté et oui ça y
est c'est fait c'est ça le problème tu
veux pas revenir en arrière
voilà alors à côté de ses commandements
lourd on introduit des commandements
léger son appel et commandement léger
c'est-à-dire
pour éviter de violer le commandement
l'eau pour éviter d'être entraîné à ton
insu et contre son gré a violé un
commandement
un commandement lourd et bien
commence par ne pas violer un
commandement léger le commandement léger
s'agit
n'accepte pas la colère dans ton coeur
comme le dira plus tard l'apôtre paul si
tu te mets en colère que le soleil ne se
couche pas sur ta colère note retient
pas ce mauvais sentiments ne nourrit pas
parce que c'est tüv allumé un feu dans
ton coeur
qui va un jour échappés à ton contre eux
et là tu vas être amené à commettre
l'irréparable que tu regretteras ensuite
ce sera trop tard
jésus ensuite prend un autre
commandement comme exemple de ce ce
qu'il a ce qu'ils enseignent la
cie le commandement de l'adultère
tu as entendu qu'il a été dit tu ne
commettras pas l'adultère
est même question qu'est ce qui peut
amener un être humain à commettre
l'adultère
la réponse est simple la convoitise
convoiter une femme
est par conséquent
tu ne commettras pas insulter c'est le
commandement lourd
ne pas convoiter la femme c'est le
commandement léger
si tu te permets d liberté de regarder
une femme pour la convoitée de regarder
de la pornographie ou des choses
semblables
tu sais pas où ça va te menu
tu tu es bien décidé bien persuadé que
jamais tu ne commettras l'adultère mais
on est tous bien sûr
si justement tu laisses la convoitise
pénétrer dans ton coeur comme je dérive
des proverbes un feu risque de s'allumer
en toi et à jour tu vas faire ce que tu
ne voulais pas faire ce que tu pensais
ne pas faire tu vas passer à l'acte
et les rabbins plaît ça mettre une et
autour de la torah pour éviter justement
de geler un commandement on met en amont
des garde-fous
pour
ne pas s'approcher du précipice si josi
est resté très loin du précipice le plus
loin possible du précipice de manière à
ne pas violer le commandement le
commandement lourds
est vrai vous ici on est dans la
tradition chrétienne
extrêmement suspicieux vis-à-vis de tout
ce qu'on appelle le légalisme
est ce que en
suivant jesus luz le raisonnement de
jésus que nous savons là dans le texte
que nous avons lu ne sommes pas en train
d'entrer dans un égal isme
alors c'était le professeur karl barth
le regretté professeur karl barth qui
était interrogé un réformé du siècle
dernier qui a eu une explication très
intéressante sujet de la torah
il a dit ceci le commandement
c'est un garde fou c'est une frontière
une frontière entre la vie et la mort
et il est vrai que aussi bien un
judaïsme que dans le christianisme j'en
ai parlé tout à l'heure on peut résumer
toute la torah à un seul nouveau un seul
mot
tout montre exactement tu aimeras un tu
aimeras le seigneur ton dieu et 2 tu
aimeras ton prochain
comme ça vous dit ça tout est dit
et professeur karl barth seat est
saint-augustin
dans une parole qui a été très très mal
comprise de sa part et qui était celle
ci aime et fais ce que tu voudras
et à partir de cette malheureuse paroles
plutôt cette parole sipa une manne
parole malheureuse et des très profonde
mais en tout cas elle est très mal
comprise via cette idée que nous sommes
affranchis de tous les commandements de
la torah du mouvement que nous aimons
et
parce que nous aimons nous avons le
droit de tout faire tout est permis tout
devient permis à partir de ce moment là
tu aimeras
mais
disait callevaert
il ya c'est pas exactement ce que ce que
ça te justin vous dis pas voulu dire
quand il n'a pas il a exclu et l'a dit
cette parole qui aime et fais ce que tu
voudras
si tu aimes ça veut dire quoi si tu
aimes
tu ne voudras que ce que la torah veut
situer rempli de l'amour de dieu
par le saint-esprit
évidemment tu ne va pas chercher à
trucider ton prochain
tu vas pas cherché à lui prendre sa
femme
tu vas pas lui chercher à lui voler
c'est bien tu vas pas cherché à le
tromper à lui mentir
tu vas pas convoiter c'est bien
donc si tu est rempli d'amour de dieu tu
vas faire spontanément ce que la torah
demande ce que la torah exige
et c'est dans ce sens là que augustin a
dit m et fais ce que tu voudras parce
qu'à ce moment là tu ne voudras que ce
que la torah veux tu vas faire
spontanément ce que la torah demande
mais ajoute-t-il
qui peut dire qui d'entre nous peut dire
qu'il est toujours remplie l'amour de
dieu
est ce que nous n'avons pas de temps en
temps des baises spirituel les uns les
autres est ce que nous n'avons pas des
moments où est bien la grille nature
comme on dit chez nous reprend le dessus
et disait karl barth à ce moment-là
bénis dieu pour le commandement quand tu
es dans un état de baisses spirituel
conduisait dans un état où tu n'es plus
remplie de cet amour de dieu et où des
mauvais sentiments par exemple les
sentiments de colère contre ton prochain
des sentiments de convoitise la vie de
la femme de ton prochain ou des
sentiments dont visa viser bien de ton
prochain te suit saisissent bénis dieu
pour le co parce qu'à ce moment là le
commandement est une frontière entre la
vie et la mort
si tu restes
en deçà du commandement tu restes dans
le domaine de la vie
si tu franchi la frontière tu entres
dans le domaine de la mort
ça ne veut pas dire que tu vas forcément
nourrir
mais ça veut dire que quand tu vas avoir
franchi cette frontière tu vas être en
danger de mort
tu pourras connaître ce drame où vous ne
pas le connaître mais d'une manière ou
d'une autre tu seras en danger de mort
et ce faisant quand tu violes le
commandement même comme l'avons dit un
petit commandement et commandement léger
et bien tu es en danger tué en danger
extrêmement grave
et
ça c'est quelque chose qui est important
pour que nous comprenions
la pensée de jésus sur sur la torah
et quand jésus va être interrogé par le
tchad la loi nous en parlions tout à
l'heure que lui demander quel est le
plus grand commandement il va citer
justement ces deux commandements que
j'évoquais tu aimeras le seigneur ton
dieu et tu aimeras ton prochain comme
toi même ça c'est toute la torah dutil
est très intéressant de noter que l'on
retrouve dans trois autres passages du
nouveau testament cette même idée
on la retrouve par exemple dans le
chapitre
xiii de l'épître aux romains verser 8 et
10 ou pal déclare ceci ne devait rien à
personne si ce n'est de vous aimer les
uns les autres car toute la torah est
accompli dans cette seule parole tu
aimeras ton prochain comme toi même
et voyez-vous ici paul fait allusion à
la deuxième des deux tables comme le
fait jésus d'ailleurs dans le sermon sur
la montagne
jésus ne commente que des commandements
qui sont tirées du 2 2 la deuxième les
deux tables ça veut dire des
devoir vis-à-vis du prochain nous avons
un deuxième texte dans l'épître aux
galates au chapitre 5 verset 14 et voit
un troisième texte qu'on retrouve dans
l'épître de jacques e chapitre 7 est
versée au chapitre ii est versée aux
pardons
et danser dans tous ces cas on retrouve
cette idée que l'amour est bien et
l'accomplissement de la torah
il y a ceux ci c'était quelque chose qui
était la manière rabbinique à l'époque
de résumer la torah tu es mal seigneur
ton dieu tu aimeras ton prochain
et d'ailleurs jésus reçoit l'approbation
du docteur de la loi qui se trouvent sur
ce plan là exactement sur la même
longueur d'onde avec lui
maintenant dans le chapitre 7 de
l'évangile de matthieu jésus va
reprendre cette idée mais sous une autre
forme nous dit ceci tout ce que vous
voulez que les en face pour vous faites
le de même pour eux parce que c'est la
torah et les prophètes
et là jésus fait allusion à une autre
manière que l'on avait de résumer la
torah aller à ceux de allen à son époque
c'est ce qu'on appelle la règle d'or
2000 elle
alors il faut savoir qu'il est et il l
est qu est ce que c'était que cette
règle d'or
il l était à rabat qui vivait un petit
siècle avant jésus
et qui
faisait partie de ce qu'on appelait les
les pères prs de rabbins qui se sont
succédé de génération en génération
après l'époque macchabées haine
et
il avait un collègue qui s'appelait
chamaillent
et il est laid chamaillent étaient deux
hommes extrêmement différents l'un de
l'autre
chamakh était un homme très rigoureux
très
très strictes à la limite même très dur
assez intransigeants
et il a le contraire était un homme
réputé pour sa grande douceur sa grande
bonté
il essayait toujours d'arranger
l'essayer toujours d'accommoder autant
qu'il pouvait le faire
c'était une époque où beaucoup de païens
s'intéresser à au judaïsme et cherchait
à se rapprocher du judaïsme
et c'est quelque chose très célèbre un
beau jour un homme d'affaires vient
enlever à trouver chamaillent et lui
tient à peu près le langage suivant
j'ai l'intention de me convertir au
judaïsme mais je suis homme d'affaires
j'ai pas le temps d'étudier au je sais
que pour se convertir il faut étudier
alors je me convertis au judaïsme à une
seule condition c'est que tu mens scène
toute la torah pendant je suis debout
sur un pied
et chamaillent lui dit tu te rends pas
compte
[Musique]
étudient la torah c'est toute une vie je
peux pas c'est pas possible tu vois la
porte elle est là tu l'apprends
notre âme s'en va et il se rend chez
elle et lui tient le même discours
et il lui dit écoute rien de plus facile
mais toi sur un pull et
l'autre se met sur un pied il lui dit ne
fais pas aux autres ce que tu ne
voudrais pas qu'il te fasse c'est toute
la torah et tout le reste ce ne sont que
des commentaires
et donc cette expression ne fais pas aux
autres ce que du muscle tu ne voudrais
pas qu'il te fasse c'est devenu une
autre manière de résumer la torah une
autre manière de davodeau de donner un
sommaire de la torah et c'est ce qu'on
appelle jusqu'à aujourd'hui le judaïsme
la règle d'or de il elle est très
intéressant de noter que dans le décret
apostolique d'actes case
quand on décide de les apôtres vous
décider de ce qu'ils vont faire des
païens qui se convertissent au
christianisme
est ce que l'on va exiger d'eux qu'ils
se convertissent au judaïsme au
préalable avant d'embrasser le
christianisme ou est ce qu'ils peuvent
entrer dans l'église en tant que payen
sans avoir à passer par le judaïsme
alors ça c'est toute la grande
discussion
qu'on trouve dans le chapitre 15 livres
des actes
finalement il est décidé d'imposer aux
païens ce qui correspond grosso modo à
ce qu'on appelle les sept lois noah chic
vient dans le judaïsme l'idée que les
païens non pas à sont dispensés de
mettre en pratique les 613 commandements
qui nous concerne que les juifs et que
dieu se contente ce qui les concerne de
sept commandements ce commandement qui
sont donc
e
reflet de notre île au monothéisme le
refus du blasphème le refus du meurtre
que le refus de l'adultère du
du vol
la non consommation du sang et puis le
fait de se doter de cour de justice pour
faire régner un minimum d'ordre dans la
société à ce titre là un païen peut
s'approcher du dieu d'israël et être
agréé par lui évidemment c'est grosso
modo ce que les apôtres vont retenir
pour ce qui concerne les païens qui
rentre dans les graisses et il ajoute
ceci plus directement les textes anciens
bon ça s'arrête là connaissent et nous a
paru bons au saint-esprit à nous de ne
pas vous imposer ou autre chose que ce
qui est nécessaire et à l'énumération
des lois
et puis ça s'arrête là mais que sa scène
des animaux et tout fait et du sens et
les dernières prescription qui sont
donnés
ça s'arrête là
mais dans les textes anciens les
manuscrits anciens nous avons inversé
qui est
ajoutée et que celui ci est qu'ils ne
fassent pas aux autres ce qu'ils ne
voudraient pas qu'il leur fasse
le professeur fou c'est penser que cet
appel en exégèse une leçon est
authentique et qu'elle a été
délibérément supprimé par les scream les
moines du moyen-âge parce que ça faisait
trop juif
donc si on retrouve la règle d'or de
hillel pour les païens cette règle d'or
de hillel elle a été élaborée en
fonction des païens et on la retrouve
dans le décret apostolique
vraisemblablement
il est intéressant de noter que jésus
reprend cette idée là mais il la met au
positif il elle disait ne fais pas aux
autres ce que tu ne voudrais pas qu'il
leur fasse je dis tout ce que vous
voulez que les hommes fassent pour vous
faites le de même pour eux parce que
c'est la torah et les prophètes
et par conséquent ici
nous avons un noyau dur
auquel jésus
ramène la torah
parce que vous avez aussi
dans le judaïsme
une hiérarchie des commandements
ça veut dire que il ya des commandements
qui sont plus importants que d'autres on
a vu déjà les petits et les grands
commandements
ça veut dire comment on loue les
commandements léger et il peut se
produire parfois qu' il y ait
un conflit entre deux entre deux
commandements
par exemple
il est interdit de voyager le jour du
shabbat
mais que faire si soudain à jour de
vous tombez sur un homme qu'il est
terrassé par une crise cardiaque
est-ce que
vous allez l'emmener à l'hôpital ou pas
si vous emmener à l'hôpital
vous violez shabbat
mais si vous emmenez pas l'hôpital
qu'est ce qui va se passer cet homme va
mourir
donc conflit entre deux commandements
celui d'aimer le prochain ou bien celui
de respecter strictement le shabbat
on considère que le reste à sauver une
vie humaine est plus important que le
respect du shabbat et dans une occasion
de ce type là on ne peut geler le
shabbat pour emmener à quelqu'un qui est
en danger de mort à l'hôpital
ou pour le soigner si c'est un médecin
c'est pourquoi aussi j'ai toujours des
médecins de garde des infirmières de
garde pour justement intervenir dans
tous les cas d'urgence ils peuvent avoir
lieu pendant le shabbat et les jours de
fête
donc il ya une hiérarchie de
commandement
et jésus nous montre qu'il en va de même
il vient mirarchi des commandements une
hiérarchie qui est en fonction de ce
commandement de l'amour
jésus ramène tout à l'amour
pourquoi par exemple va-t-on gelé le
shabbat
pour sauver quelqu'un qui est en danger
de mort
et bien parce que
le but de la torah c'est la vie le but
du commandement c'est la vie la torah
est une torah de vie et non pas une
torah de mort
et
jésus nous montre plutôt
l'interprétation d'un commandement c'est
toujours de 2 chère chercher
pardon et de choisir la vie choisi la
vie afin que tu vives
ccg mis devant toile le chemin de la vie
le chemin de la mort le chemin de la
bénédiction juin de la malédiction a
trouvé ça à la fin du niveau du
deutéronome choisi choisi la vie pour
que tu veux choisir le bon moment c'est
choisir la vie donc une interprétation
du commandement qui conduit à la mort ne
peut pas être une interprétation juste
c'est précisément ce que disait tout à
l'heure c'est à bonnut le commandement
que donner une interprétation qui va
aboutir à la mort
par contre donné une interprétation du
commandement qui aboutit à la vie c'est
établir le commandant
jésus nous montre que toute
interprétation d'un commandement qui
n'est pas directement en relation avec
l'amour qui n'a pas pour but non
seulement la vie mais l'édification
l'amour du prochain ne peux pas c'est
simplement une à une interprétation est
exacte
toute interprétation du commandement est
forcément une commande à une
interprétation qui va dans ce sens que
nous avons évoqué là
et qui est écrit et donc
spécifique aussi le message de jésus
jésus est allé beaucoup plus loin que la
plupart des sages de son temps
qui se contentait de
recommander de ne pas haïr les nuits
mais jésus allé jusqu'à demander un
amour positive de l'ennemi
et
c'est ce que vous trouvez semaine
quelque chose de semblable dans l'épître
aux galates les enfin fameux incident
d'antioche là le conflit entre entre
pierre et paul à antioch
quand donc
paul plus tôt pierre mangé avec des noms
des noms juifs
ce qui à l'époque nazie était interdit
dans le giron du cas le plus strict de
l'époque aa
et convient viennent des envoyés de
jacques qui sont ultra judaïsants ils se
séparent deux
épaules leur prend d'une manière très
sévère en disant attention que je suis
en train de faire là
pour le respect d'un commandement mineur
celui du respecter strictement la
cacherout tu es en train de
donner une véritable gifle à thé frère
païen
et tu es en train de faire en sorte que
ce soit des ce soit des gens qui
que tu rejettes donc tu n'agit pas dans
l'amour donc tu n'accomplit pas le
véritable commandement le commandement
voudrais que tu continues à manger avec
ces gens là même si pour des gens qui
sont extrêmement strictes comme les
envoyés de jacques bien tu violes ici à
un commandement qui d'ailleurs pas
véritablement comment mon public puisque
même aujourd'hui il n'est plus respecté
le judaïsme actuelle
donc
le commandement de l'amour ici est
essentiel tout ramener à l'amour mais
n'ont pas encore une fois un amour vague
comme on disait dans cette auguste tient
mais quelque chose qui est extrêmement
pratique et on a on a compté le nombre
des commandements bien sûr dans
l'écriture 613 commandements
et combien de commandement dans le
nouveau testament
le 15 c'est
non
mais ils disent
c'est pas moi qui les ai comptés
vous voyez vous
la mousse et de garder lé commandement
du seigneur jésus dit ça exactement si
vous m'aimez mais garder mes
commandements et c'est comme ça que vous
serez mais de mon père
dernier point avant de conclure
on nous dira mais
jésus bon soit
jésus n'a pas aboli la torah c'est un
fait
mais paul lafay ce que jésus n'a pas
fait paul l'a fait et on citera un
certain nombre de textes notamment dans
l'épître aux romains
je ne vais pas
entrer dans ce débat d'une manière
approfondie ce soir parce que c'est pas
mon sujet mon sujet s'était la torah
dans le sermon sur la montagne
mais je devais simplement lire a inversé
dans le chapitre 3 de l'épître aux
romains ou pas nous dit ceci
chapitre 3
verset 31 est ce que nous allions la
torah par la foi
au contraire nous établissons la torah
est ici paul
met en opposition ce qu'il appelle la
justification par les oeuvres de la
torah
donc ça s'est très très mal comprises
dans le christianisme actuel avec les
réformateurs qui se sont complètement
trompés sur ce plan là on considère que
là
la torah disons là
le fait de la coupure des oeuvres morale
justifiés
en fait c'est tout à fait différent de
cela ce que pour la paix les oeuvres la
torah c'est tout simplement appartenir
au peuple d'israël
a pas seulement on appartient au peuple
d'israël on est sauvé on est justifié
on est sauvé donc par le fait de vivre à
la juive c'est à dire du respecté les
commandements rituel
est pas une gestation
si tu te contentes de respecter les
grandes mutuelles mais que tu ne
respectes pas les commandements moreau
et bien ton appartenance au peuple
d'israël ne sert à rien du tout
et il cite l'exemple d'abraham abraham
cru en dieu et cela fut imputé à justice
et puis ici de le texte d'abacus le
juste vivre à part la fois
et
il voit tout de suite le contresens
qu'on peut faire sur son propos
et s'imaginer que la fois cette fois
dont parle habacuc le juste vivre à part
la foi de sa digue benmouna torride et
en hébreu ce qui peut aussi signifier la
fidélité de dieu juste vivre à part la
fidélité de dieu
et bien cette
cette idée bien annuler la torah
et
le général les lecteurs non juifs finir
une chose
c'est que dans le judaïsme de l'époque
de paul et même de plus en plus tardifs
le
texte habacuc c'est une confirmation de
la torah
yann moïse a donné 613 commandements dit
un texte
alors je suis plus exactement
commencer enfin ça a été réduit moïse et
en 1613
david les a réduits
michel les a réduits à 5
et puis habacuc les a réduits à un seul
c'est encore une manière de résumer les
sociétés de la torah le juste vivre à
part la fois par conséquent la fois
n'annule pas la torah mais elle le
confirme
et paul rappelle cela dit attention ne
vous méprenez pas sur ce que je dis
quand je dis que le salut se fait par la
foi et non pas par les oeuvres de la
torah ça ne signifie pas que la torah
est abonnée au contraire elle est
confirmée nous dit l'apôtre il emploie
les mêmes eaux que jésus les cayes est
moulé va-t-elle donc il y as
parfaitement harmonie entre jésus et
paul sur le plan de la torah
contrairement à ce qu'on a fait de paul
un anti un anti torah et encore
aujourd'hui à la fois du judaïsme et
dans le christianisme ce qu'on pense
d'eux paul beaucoup plus que pour sucrer
de jésus mais là aussi ça ne tient pas
la route alors je conclue en disant eh
bien
la torah dans le sermon sur la montagne
jésus l'établé et encore une fois il ne
s'agit pas ici de légalisme ça n'a rien
à voir
avec une respect légaliste de la torah
mais selon le sermon sur la montagne ne
conduit pas à l'accomplissement de la
torah par amour tout ce que vous voulez
que les hommes fassent pour vous faites
le de même pour eux c'est la torah et
les prophètes tu aimeras le seigneur ton
dieu tu aimeras ton prochain comme toi
même mais comme le disions avec augustin
il arrive malheureusement parce que nous
sommes des hommes
êtres humains ou l'amour de dieu n'aime
plus dans nos coeurs et vous des
sentiments mauvais prennent le relais et
à ce moment là le commandement est un
point de repère et un poteau indicateur
est une frontière entre la vie et la
mort qui pour nous est d'une extrême
importance parce que nouvelle permet de
rester dans le domaine de la vie et je
rappellerai pour terminer cette parole
que j'ai cités tout à l'heure
kate à la fin du 2 0 nomme j'ai mis
devant toi de chemin je mets de la ville
je peins de la mort le chemin de la
bénédiction une semaine la malédiction
je mène la vie de la bénédiction c'est
tellement pratique douce et commandement
que je prescris aujourd'hui je mende à
mort et la malédiction site au contraire
rencontrer tous les viols j'ai bu selon
toi devant toi ces deux chemins choisi
la vie afin que tu veux
voilà je voulais vous dire ce soir